bonsoir madame bonsoir alors la pandémie
là ça a été comme une grande parenthèse
lorsqu'on voulait faire des analyses du
marché de l'emploi difficile de trouver
nos repères pendant cette période-là
maintenant qu'on a une nouvelle
normalité qu'est-ce qui vous a marqué le
plus dans le bilan de l'emploi que vous
avez dressé alors on a beaucoup parlé de
la pandémie comme d'un accélérateur on a
adopté le télétravail on va au cinéma à
la maison mais qu'on parle du marché de
l'emploi ça aussi été un électrochoc à
créer de nouveaux phénomènes absentéisme
vous l'avez dit déplacement des
travailleurs
des changements structurels du marché du
travail finalement oui une des données
collier présentait là vraiment très
intéressant les emplois mieux rémunérés
et je trouve que les données sont
vraiment frappantes quand on dit il y a
plus d'un demi million d'emplois c'est
presque 532 000 emplois de plus à 30
dollars et plus de l'heure mais en
contrepartie on a l'impression que c'est
un déplacement des emplois qui étaient
payés à moins de 20 dollars de l'heure
une perte de ce côté là on présume
qu'ils sont donc passés dans la
catégorie supérieure qu'est-ce qui
explique tout ça est-ce que c'est la
pénurie d'emploi est-ce que c'est
l'inflation ou est-ce qu'encore les
employeurs ont carrément répondu à
l'appel de François Legault crée des
emplois bien rémunérés alors il y a
peut-être deux choses qui sont à lèvres
ici les salaires ont augmenté en moyenne
parce qu'il y a des tensions sur le
marché de travail parce qu'on se bat
contre une inflation qui est galopante
mais donc il y a plus de travailleurs
qui sont passés finalement dans cette
catégorie de 30 dollars et plus mais
aussi on a eu des déplacements entre les
secteurs on l'a vu les secteurs qui ont
été le plus touchés par la pandémie la
restauration l'hôtellerie le commerce de
détails ont tous perdu un nombre
important de travailleurs alors qu'il y
a d'autres secteurs en moyenne mur
rémunérés comme les services
professionnels qui eux ont gagné aux
changes autre constat vraiment très
intéressant et on va voir un autre
graphique d'ailleurs à ce sujet là grand
déséquilibre dans la scolarité des
emplois et là ce qu'on voit là c'est que
dans dans le groupe de bandes à gauche
on voit à 89 000 emplois le besoin des
employeurs pour des postes qui n'exigent
aucune scolarité minimale un grand écart
avec le nombre de chômeurs disponibles
donc ça ça ressemble on voit donc il y a
plus de postes disponibles que de
travailleurs qui le sont et à l'inverse
complètement à droite du graphique on
voit l'écart inverse c'est-à-dire
beaucoup plus de travailleurs qualifiés
qui ont un grade universitaire que de
postes disponible pour cette catégorie
là
le niveau d'éducation des Québécois
augmente est-ce que est-ce que cette
tendance là reste de s’alourdir alors il
y a deux choses qui sont à l’œil il y a
les jeunes et les personnes qui sont au
travail aujourd'hui sont plus
scolarisées que ceux qui quittent qui
prennent leur retraite actuellement donc
le niveau de scolarité monte en même
temps notre demande en travailleur elle
est encore elle mise beaucoup encore sur
des postes plus scolarisés aussi on les
employeurs ont se passe on doivent
recruter constamment parce que les
travailleurs ont quitté ces emplois
parce que jusqu'à récemment on avait une
reprise post pandémique qui remplissent
les restaurants remplissent les bons de
commande et donc qui viennent gonfler
cette demande pour des postes qui
requièrent peu de scolarité oui mais
c'est le tiers des postes de vacances
madame Brahm là 89000 dans les secteurs
qui demandent une scolarité minimale on
les employeurs ont recours bon
évidemment entre autres à une main
d'oeuvre étrangère temporaire
quelles autres options ont-ils puisque à
l'évidence il manque de candidats à
court terme on le voit le recours au
travailleur temporaire il a augmenté
pendant la pandémie ça a doublé entre
2018 et aujourd'hui c'est une des
solutions à court terme après à plus
long terme qu'est-ce qu'on voit
automatiser ça fait augmenter la
productivité automatisée parfois juste
certaines tâches l'accès à des outils
numériques avoir recours à ses talents
qualifiés qu'on a qui peuvent être plus
polyvalents plus performants mais c'est
aussi beaucoup réorganiser le travail
comment est-ce qu'on gère ressources
humaines comment on travaille en équipe
comment on gère les tâches dans une
équipe ça c'est un élément qui peut
augmenter la productivité et puis on va
le voir et on le voit déjà des modèles
d'affaires qui s'adaptent notamment en
restauration on le voit on trouve des
nouveaux modèles d'affaires on change
les heures de travail les journées de
travail pour s'adapter finalement à
cette main d'oeuvre moins abondante
qu'avant donc pour s'adapter à la
manœuvre moins abondante mais aussi
réduire cet écart Olivier nous
présentait l'écart de productivité du
travail si vous voulez entre le Québec
et l'Ontario on est plus gourmand en
travailleur c'est ce que vous disiez
dans votre rapport madame brame pourquoi
c'est comme ça parce que notre étude
elle révèle de nouveau c'est que pour
créer la même richesse on a besoin de
plus de travailleurs au Québec et donc
par exemple pour créer un milliard de
dollars de PIB au Québec on a besoin de
17% de plus de travailleurs qu'on
Ontario pourquoi notamment parce qu'on
mise encore beaucoup sur ces postes peu
qualifiés et
qu'on ne trouve pas de candidat pour les
combler donc ça demande elle gonfle et
elle vient réduire finalement notre
productivité ça illustre l'ampleur des
défis qui sont toujours devant nous au
chapitre du marché de l'emploi Abraham
merci beaucoup d'avoir été là merci à
vous pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]